19 30
30 bien bonsoir Monsieur Chirac nous
arrivons au terme de cette campagne
électorale il vous reste en quelque
sorte deux émissions donc de 15 minutes
30 minutes pour convaincre alors je
viens vous savez de ma province je viens
de Marseille superbe province oui que
vous connaissez bien je crois pour y
avoir passé une partie de vre enfance et
que j'aime beaucoup et et j'entends ce
que disent les gens je vais donc vous
poser les questions qui me pose et qu'il
se POS à votre propos et naturellement à
propos de cette campagne électorale la
première question peut-être un peu
provocatrice c'est celle-ci on me dit je
crois que c'est vrai que les socialistes
sont en train déjà de former leur
nouveau gouvernement on me dit par
exemple Claude Viller est en train de
préparer le scénario la mise en scène de
la fête de la Bastille dimanche soir
après la victoire de Monsieur miteran
alors si
fichu et vous avez même pu voir que le
candidat socialiste a décidé
samedi d'aller à une réunion
internationale et d'y prononcer un
discours dont personne n'imagine qu'il
puisse être autre chose qu'un discours
de chef d'État et bien je crois que
Monsieur mitéran A T car il ne faut pas
préjuger de ce que sera le vote de
dimanche
prochain il ne faut pas avoir en quelque
sorte l'insolence de considérer que les
choses sont acquises et qu'on a une espè
de droit à maintenir sa position et sa
situation et Monsieur mitan pourrait
bien être déçu ainsi que les socialistes
dimanche Soiron
ça c'est votre conviction mais je voudis
que vous me fassiez partager c'estd
qu'est-ce qui en vous vous dit que ça
n'est pas
perdu d'abord monsieur bass parce que
lorsque j'engage un
combat et notamment sur le plan
politique ou sur le plan économique
quand j'ai engagé le combat contre le
chômage
je considère que je dois gagner j'en
suis profondément
convaincu je suis prêt à assumer la
responsabilité de l'échec mais je suis
convaincu de gagner et ceci jusqu'au
dernier jour mais je ne préjuge pas du
résultat je fais confiance aux
électrices et aux électeurs voilà alors
bon je crois qu'il faut quand même aller
un tout petit peu plus loin si vous me
permettez il que vous me donniez ce
soir deux raisons pour voter dimanche
pour vous je pourrais vous en donner
beaucoup plus de deux deux
deux j'en choisirai alors l'une dans le
domaine de la politique au sens noble du
terme et l'autre dans le domaine de la
vie
quotidienne dans le domaine de la
politique j'ai une majorité qui m'a
soutu loyalement et qui continue de me
soutenir
loyalement ce qui veut dire que si je
suis élu dès la proclamation des
résultats
je formmerai un gouvernement qui
engagera immédiatement une politique de
redressement dans le droitfil de celle
qui a conduit depuis 2 ans mais en
tenant compte à la fois de tout ce qui a
été exprimé par Monsieur bar bien
entendu et qui est cohérent avec mon
propre projet mais aussi du message reçu
le 24 avr monsieur dit pas autre chose
Monsieur dit moi je nommerai Premier
ministre dans les 48 he oui mais la
grand diff c'est que moi j'ai une
majorité qui pour 3 ans existe et qui
par conséquent assure la stabilité de
nos institutions et permet d'engager
l'activité gouvernementale tout de suite
tandis que le candidat socialiste
nommera peut-être un premier ministre
etessa par un certain nombre de
combinesouch qui se produisent déjà oui
sans succès mais enfin on en voit
quelquesuns bien peu et permettez-moi de
le dire bien modeste et il ne pourra pas
rester dans cette situation devra donc
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale et nous
sommes repartis si j'ose dire pour un
tour c'estàdire un nouveau débat
national sur les mêmes thèmes avec les
mêmes affrontements avec les mêmes
risques de division est-ce que vous
croyez vraiment que face au problèm
auquel elle est confronté le chômage la
pauvreté la concurrence économique de
l'Europe de demain les problèmes de
sécurité les problèmes d'immigration et
cetera la France a le temps a consacrer
au lieu de se rassembler dans un effort
rapide à un nouveau débat un nouveau
débat
politicien c'est ça l'élection du
candidat socialiste c'est l'ouverture
sur l'incertitude peut-être sur une
certaine forme d'aventure et en tous les
cas sur la paralysie pour un temps assez
long des pouvoirs publics nous n'avons
pas les moyens de cela alors ça c'est la
raison politique il y en a une autre qui
est une raison je dirais qui tient au
cœur des Français plus que tout autre
c'est la lutte contre le
chômage pendant 5 ans monsieur mitteran
a gouverné avec les pleins pouvoirs il y
a eu 700000 chômeurs de plus je n'ai
gouverné que 2 ans j'ai commencé par
stabiliser le chômage pour la première
fois depuis 15 ans et j'ai engagé le
processus de décroissance depuis mars 87
il y a 5 % de chômeurs de moins et 15 %
de jeunes chômeurs de moins et j'entends
poursuivre cette action les socialistes
en sont incapables ils l'ont prouvé et
démontré malgré leurs engagements
antérieurs moi j'entends poursuivre une
action tendant à répondre à ce problème
il y aurait bien d'autres raisons bien
sûr alors maintenant la pruve inverse
donnez-moi deux raisons pour ne pas
voter mitérant dimanche moi aussi je
pourrais vous en donner beaucoup plus de
deux mais je prendrai d'abord la
première et qui est le pendant de ce que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure le candidat
socialiste n'a pas de majorité il faudra
qu'il trouve une majorité pour soutenir
l'action de son gouvernement ce qui
suppose à l'évidence soit des magouilles
politicienne qui paralyseront l'action
de ce gouvernement soit une dissolution
et un nouveau débat national un peu
paralysant lui aussi et
divisant la deuxème raison c'est que
monsieur mittiran a fait les preuve de
ce qu'il savait faire entre 81 et
85 jamais le chômage n'a autant augmenté
jamais l'insécurité ne s'est autant
développé notamment la délinquence et la
criminalité le terrorisme aussi jamais
l'immigration a été aussi mal contrôlée
et l'immigration clandestine si tolérée
avec indulgence et je pourrais
multiplier les exemples jamais les
déficitsi ont été aussi importants en 5
ans la gestion socialiste s'est traduite
par le fait qu'on a multiplié par 3 la
dette intérieure de la France par 4 sa
dette extérieure par 5 le déficit
budgétaire et tout cela cela suppose que
demain on soit obligé de prélever sur le
porte-monnaie de nos concitoyens c'est
un bilan totalement négatif que vous
présentez de bilan ne sont jamais
totalement négatifs mais le bilan global
a été négatif alors comment pourrait-il
demain alors qu'il ne nous a jamais dit
je me suis trompé et je ferai le
contraire de ce que j'ai fait hier mais
d'ailleurs s'il l'avait dit je lui
aurais répondu mais si vous voulez faire
le contraire de ce que vous avez fait
hier c'est c'est-à-dire si vous voulez
faire oui si vous voulez faire ce que
moi j'ai fait je suis probablement mieux
à même de le faire que vous donc nous
restons dans ce flou et cette ambiguité
nous ne pouvons pas faire confiance à un
homme qui a échouer une première fois et
qui prétend en refusant d'évoquer les
vrais problèmes que je citais tout à
l'heure obtenir un chèque en blanc au
nom de l'incantation au nom du verbe au
nom du flou je n'ai pas confiance et
par-dessus le marché il a montré à quel
point il avait une tendance ou une
aptitude à cacher la vérité à travestir
la vérité au français et bien vous
faites allusion à l'affire Gorg je fais
notamment allusion à l'affaire gorgie où
son comportement m'a profondément choqué
on n'a pas le droit de travestir la
vérité lorsqu'on s'adresse au français
bien alors allons quand même un peu plus
loin je suis parpèse bien sûr un
électeur centriste qu'est-ce que vous me
dites alors que on sent qu'il y a un peu
de trouble dans ce secteur qu'est-ce que
vous me dites pour me convaincre de
voter pour vous en ben
je suis stupéfait par cette campagne
développée par les socialistes et qui
tente à faire apparître je oui c'est
leur jeu mais qui tente à faire
apparaître les centristes comme des
espèces de de gens sans
conviction
versatil moi je connais bien les
centristes ils font partie de ma
majorité ils m'ont soutenu dans les
moments les plus difficiles avec une
loyauté parfaite et rien ne me permet de
dire aujourd'hui que tout d'un coup ils
sont pris des d'â je les ai vu mobiliser
naturellement ils ont peut-être plus que
d'autres des préoccupations que j'ai
intégré et qui sont celles de la justice
sociale qui sont celles de la
construction européenne mais nous
n'avons pas de divergence de vue dans
ces domaines moi je fais parfaitement
confiance au centristes et je n'essaie
pas de débaucher qui que ce soit oui pr
précisément puisquon parle des gens qui
qui sont débauchés j'en ai entendu hier
soir qui disait à la télévision qu'il
avait retrouvé
dans le programme de Monsieur mitan les
thèmes programme de Monsieur bar
monsieur bass moi aussi dans ce que je
peux appeler le programme car il est
bien léger de Monsieur miteran je trouve
des éléments auquels je souscris quand
monsieur miteran dit il faut que tout le
monde soit plus heureux c'est un
objectif que je partage parfaitement
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que les
socialistes quel que soi leurs ambitions
pour le bonheur des hommes je n'en doute
pas de leur réalité ont toujours été
incapa de créer par une véritable
politique économique et une gestion de
nos affaires les conditions permettant
de financer le progrès social le progrès
social a eu lieu quand il a eu lieu en
France essentiellement et d'ailleurs à
l'étranger aussi lorsque les socialistes
étaient dans l'opposition lorsqu'ils
prennent le pouvoir ils gèrent nos
affaires de façon telle que queles que
soi leurs bonnes intentions ou leurs
ambitions la France s'appauvrit et
s'appauvrissant elle ne peut pas
financer les actions nécessaires de
justice social et de progrès social
c'est la raison pour laquelle on ne peut
pas leur faire confiance c'est pas un un
procès d'intention sur les objectifs
c'est l'incapacité dans laquelle ils
sont de créer les moyens permettant
d'atteindre ces objectifs voilà voilà
pour ils ont stérilisé nos entreprises
en les surchargeant ils ont empêché
l'investissement ils ont ruiné les
contribuables en dépensant à tout VAT
dans les conditions dont on n même pas
retrouvé les traces ils ont fait avec le
secteur nationalisé des trous
considérables dans les déficits et par
conséquent dans ce qu'ils ont demandé à
nos compatriotes de financer c'est pas
comme ça naturellement que l'on peut
financer le progrès social l'activité
minimum
d'insertion garantie que j'ai proposé
pour être la nouvelle conquête sociale
du prochain septénat plus ou moins
d'ailleurs si oui mais sous forme
d'assistance il il faut donner un chèque
à ceux qui en ont besoin naturellement
qu'il le faut et que la lutte contre la
priorit la lutte contre la pauvreté est
avec la lutte contre le chômage une
priorité absolue mais moi je dis qu'il
faut donner certainer un chèque mais
aussi mais aussi tendre la main à ceux
qui en ont besoin leur donner les moyens
de conserver leur dignité par le fait
que faisant un effort soit d'insertion
soit de formation soit de travail il
puisse justifier le l'argent qu'il gagne
et la protection sociale qu'on le assure
c'est un problème de dignité alors
avançons un peu je suis par hypothèse
toujours électeur du Front national
qu'est-ce que vous me dites pour que je
vote pour vous
dimanche j'indique simplement que sur
les principales préoccupations qui
peuvent être ceux qui d'ailleurs ont
voté soit à droite soit à gauche dans un
vote protestataire le 24 avril je leur
dis simplement comparer ce qu'a fait
monsieur miteran et ce que j'ai fait
comparer ce qui il dit et ce que je dis
vous êtes inquiet pour la
sécurité voyez le l'amorce de
rétablissement de notre sécurité et que
je poursuivrai vous êtes inquiet pour le
chômage voyez que mon gouvernement est
le premier qui a lutté efficacement
contre ce fléo social vous êtes inquiet
pour la sécurité sociale voyez que mon
gouvernement a rétabli l'équilibre des
comptes qui avait été si perturbé par la
gestion socialiste vous êtes inquiet
pour l'identité nationale voyez comment
j'ai lutté contre l'immigration
clandestine comment j'ai fermé nos
frontières et que je les ai contrôlé et
je pourrais multiplier les exemples vous
êtes inquiet sur la façon dont on va
aborder l'Europe voyez comment j'ai
redonné aux entreprises la possibilité
d'investir et donc d'être compétitif
comment j'ai défendu les intérêts de nos
paysans à Bruxelles de nos industriels
de nos artisans de nos commerçants des
professions libérales pour qu'elles
abordent cette Europe de demain avec
toutes les chances d'être victorieuse et
juger à parttir de là qui par son passé
par les preuves qu'il a donné par ses
ambitions claires et le mieux à même de
satisfaire vos propres ambitions alors
Monsieur enfin je suis tenté par
l'abstention dimanche qu'est-ce que vous
me dites pourqui je ne m'abtienne
pas c'est vrai que certains peuvent être
tentés par
l'abstention je voudrais les mettre en
garde d'abord parce que s'abstenir n'est
pas une attitude responsable
devant l'importance des
enjeux devant les problèmes auxquels
nous sommes confrontés nous devons
prendre position le courage et je dirais
le sens civique nous y
oblige à partir de là si ce qu'a fait
monsieur mitteran entre 81 et 85 vous a
convaincu du bien fondé de sa démarche
si le flou actuel de son propos ses
incantations vous conviennent et si vous
êtes prêt à lui donner un chèque en
blanc alors oui votez pour lui mais si
vous doutez de
cela référez-vous à ce que j'ai fait
dans des condition difficile pendant 2
ans et alors voter pour moi mais
s'abstenir en toute hypothèse et vous
devez le savoir et le comprendre
s'abstenir c'est voter pour Monsieur
mitteran et par conséquent contre ce que
vous pensez
profondément que nous nous retrouverons
demain soir nous parlerons de Monsieur
Le Pen du racisme de la nouvelle
caléonie et cetera à demain demain soir
à demain
soir